I believe it is relevant and it can have
a concrete and positive impact people
need doorways to explore universal
religious and ethical ideas pope john
paul ii probably beatified more saints
than any other pope in history he
understood that we need modern doorways
in order to drink from very very deep
wells and I think occultism or New Age
spirituality or alternative spirituality
rather than steering people into dark
corners very frequently particularly in
our country
steers people toward a renewed interest
in universal religious and ethical ideas
that they might never encounter if they
didn't find a modern and novel door to
enter the tradition with in my book I
write quite a bit about an early 20th
century psychic named Edgar Cayce he was
claimed to be a medical Claire bland who
could diagnose people's diseases people
that he had never met people who were
far away
his readings his psychical readings also
contain a great deal of ethical material
there's a whole generation of people who
I think came in touch with all kinds of
Eastern and gospel based religious ideas
because they saw Edgar Cayce as a person
who shone a modern light as a person who
was able to offer some kind of invisible
help in the contemporary world that's
the experience of people who encounter
Saints in the Catholic Church then we
need to see people who look and talk and
live and act like us sometimes before we
can turn a knob and open a door that's
what occultism has always provided in
the mid 19th century a cult figures in
this country were confirming the most
radically held views that came out of
the Reformation they were confirming an
idea that each individual had a kind of
birthright to a non mediated encounter
with the divine and I think spiritualism
mesmerism the mental healing movement
provided some people with the most
meaning
experiences of their lives these
movements also demanded that religion be
not just a salvation ofourse but that it
be a healing force as well and that's
probably the most significant legacy of
the occult in this country throughout
this nation and throughout many parts of
the modern Western world churches and
religious organizations are required to
address the practical needs of people's
day-to-day existence salvation as a name
hasn't been jettisoned but people demand
that hand in hand with that the church
play a therapeutic role so you find a
self-help spirituality that spans our
religious landscape from the new age to
evangelical media ministries the the the
the most easily adaptable a cult idea
has been what we basically call the
positive thinking movement which in its
earliest inception grew out of mesmerist
circles in this country in the mid 19th
century in New England in the
burned-over district the idea that the
mind had causative power was a concept
that came out of mesmerism that has been
reworked across our social landscape you
find it in the speeches of Ronald Reagan
you find it in business motivation
seminars you it's the stock-in-trade of
life coaches you also find that idea
ensconced in the sermons that have
figure like Joel Osteen will give every
Sunday morning to a television audience
of tens of millions of people it's also
a New Age idea that you find expressed
in the secret this concept that religion
had to be cathartic religion had to be
healing religion had to be practical was
unheard of say a hundred and fifty years
ago you didn't hear that
within the Catholic Church you didn't
hear of that within Calvinist
Protestantism you started to hear of it
within occult circles and eventually
that became an American innovation whose
roots became somewhat hidden but it just
spread throughout the entire culture I
think that's been a positive trend I
think therapeutic spirituality has
largely been a help in in the modern
world so the fact that people can
approach religion with practical needs
and
times that they feel the need to
approach religion through either novelty
or or or in some kind of modern terms
that is an aspect of human nature and I
think that anything that helps people
draw closer to some sort of a
universalist or religious ethic is
probably for the net good in the end and
and to me that's part of the role that
alternative spirituality has played